good morning John
so I have found myself in a very
peculiar position that I did not ask to
be in and do not particularly want to be
in which is that I live in the state of
Montana which is the first state to pass
a tick tock band also
high on the person in the state of
Montana with
I think I don't know more Tick Tock
followers than anyone else it doesn't
like a list so that means that reporters
have been calling me and The Tick Tock
people have been calling me
Tick Tock like comms people they're like
would you like to comment on this also
local reporters and I really like to
talk to reporters like I think that it's
a good thing to do but at this point
it's kind of weird that I haven't talked
about it it's like weird that I wouldn't
I don't know what this is
trash
what's that oh that's like a fishing
lure so that's a weird situation to be
in and I guess you're probably asking
yourself okay well why don't you just
talk about it then Hank honestly
because I don't know what to say so
first of all can you ban Tick Tock in
the state of Montana uh kind of maybe
but probably at least at the moment no
the idea of the ban which is headed to
the desk of Governor Greg gianforte who
I think is expected to sign it is that
you wouldn't be able to download tick
tock on your phone from an app store and
I don't like that I don't want there to
be like a fractured internet where some
states have different internet than
other states that seems bad but also
maybe seems unconstitutional I do
imagine this will be fought in a number
of ways in the courts um as with so much
these days it seems performative
it seems like the goal is to get people
to talk about it not to actually do
something not to achieve a goal to
perform governance rather than to govern
now I don't think that a national Tick
Tock ban would be that way I don't
pretend to understand the intricacies of
international relations between the U.S
and China the future that that
relationship might bring and what the
Chinese government would do with its
influence over Tick Tock today seems
like potentially a very different thing
than they would do with its influence
over Tick Tock in 10 years you know we
all watched as these platforms were used
to
Rend Societies in different ways over
the last
few years and it's not a good vibe and I
totally understand being worried about
that whether it is using that to spy on
high-profile individuals or if it's used
to sort of put your finger on the scale
and promote content that
creates more Rifts in our society which
these platforms have done already on
their own for purely economic reasons
and I don't see why they couldn't also
do it for political reasons if they were
asked to by a government which does
require companies that operate in that
country to do what they say at the same
time we've never dealt with
the removal of not just speech but an
entire platform for speech you know I
don't think that Tick Tock is just a
place where content goes I think that it
is many cultures and as many genres and
many things are created there
and will be created there that would not
be created somewhere else so I don't
think on a national scale that this is
easy I think we've gotten ourselves into
a pretty weird situation honestly I
think I've gotten myself into a pretty
weird situation but I think on the scale
of the state of Montana
um that it's a lot of the same
performative stuff that is just
infuriating me generally a lot right now
it's just a bunch of people over
obsessed with whatever is being talked
about on Fox news that day and I don't
really know if it's good to pour a bunch
of attention on it because I live in a
state where the people I vote for are
not going to be in the majority anytime
soon and the other people win points for
doing this BS and they like it when it
gets attention so I don't really know
what to do about that but shout out to
all the more sane voices in the Montana
legislature it's a hard time to be doing
what you're doing uh but I appreciate
you John I'll see you on Tuesday